[Music]  the Winter Olympics as I said supposed  to start in two days this has been all  over the Internet this picture of a  Sochi bathroom stall with two toilets  has been making the rounds and then  someone tweeted this picture of a toilet  facing free chair  [Applause]  that one's known as the job interview  yeah well today even stranger bathroom  configurations of surface there's this  toilet five feet off the ground there's  a toilet over another toilet good thing  there's a bar there there's a toilet  next to a sushi chef I found that very  strange there are these ski lift toilets  I don't even know how that works  finally the Olympic metal stand itself  ladies enjoy  [Applause]